God bless you thank you for letting me
into your home nice to meet you sir
[Music]
they're smiling
they look normal they look normal Miss
Debbie what you trying to say were they
supposed to look different
um
well uh Debbie meets osama's parents for
the first time and they have something
to say about her and usama's 40-plus
year age difference did they feel bad
like me at first about it
plus we get a sneak peek at next week's
episode that completely made me lose the
little bit of positive feeling I even
had tour Debbie in osama's relationship
our plan is it will bring me to the USA
and we start Outlet there if you don't
accept this we can't stop always
Osama said here I am let's not waste any
more time
let's get into it
hey naughty day fans fam it's melicia I
hope you are doing well let's get into
Debbie and Usama after spending a couple
of days in Rabat Osama and I are finally
headed to chemiset to meet his family
the day Debbie has been dreading has
arrived you know that age difference
thing it's like who's in a hurry to meet
Mom and Dad not me
and even though she's extremely nervous
her lighthearted side can't help but
ooze out wow who the man who the man who
the man in charge yeah
Miss Debbie knows how to make Usama feel
like a king you larger than charge Osama
as they start to head to salma's
Hometown Debbie reveals her worst fear
meeting usama's parents I'm thinking
they're gonna think I'm some terrible
American trying to steal their son and
once they arrive at his family's home
all she wants to do is hide what did I
get myself into follow me don't worry
unfollow me just put a bag over in my
head okay
disagree
just put a bag over in my head okay
before they walk in Usama gives Debbie
one of those stage mom pep talks give me
the smile give me the smile yep the
smile is everything without smile we're
not made them in my head I'm thinking
[Music]
smile please smile and no surprise
Debbie knocks the smile out of the park
let's go
hi once she says hello to everyone
Debbie tells the camera her first
impression of usama's family they're
smiling they look normal they look kind
and I feel like an honored guest and I'm
I'm really rather surprised to be honest
with you as everyone attempts to adjust
to the energy in the room
there is a bit of awkward silence but
with Debbie's bubbly personality the
conversation starts to pick up
look at that
special
wow your dad's cool I told you you learn
from your daddy always act like that
good man okay
she gets osama's family laughing even
though I don't think they're
understanding half of what she's saying
and usama's Dad officially welcomes
Debbie by telling her their home is her
home after this I guess Debbie felt
comfortable enough to address the
elephant in the room the fact that she's
67 and Usama
is 24. you know it was really really
hard for me to accept the age difference
between Osama and myself
but because of his heart and his words
were beautiful we have an unusual
relationship but it's connected in art
and honesty and good intention oh yeah
oh yeah talker I don't think she said
anything during the entire conversation
which is disappointing because she was
the main person I wanted to hear from
you can see she was thinking a lot and I
want to know what it is
but on the way to the house Usama warned
Debbie that his mother is a lady of very
few words according to him she's really
shy
all right let's at least hear usama's
Dad's reaction to Debbie's age
he said like it's it's not a button for
him what's up option for him is if you
understand me and understand you thank
you sir that was a polite answer to give
to Debbie but osama's Dad told the
camera how he really felt
um
foreign
[Music]
's parents their age and while it was
crickets from his mom his dad revealed
he's 68 just a year older than Debbie we
can all do the math I
I'm glad Dad is a little bit older
though
yeah I kept thinking maybe I'm older
than dead
yeah you know man
I love when Debbie puts on that voice
yeah you the old man
[Applause]
who the man
who the man in charge yeah
to think that she locked herself away
for 12 years I miss Debbie for uplifting
people but I I never got the chance
because I was wallowing in my own
depression I'm glad she's out and about
now shining that light even if she is in
a very strange relationship a part of me
is given a big sigh of relief when they
said they accept the age difference
even though there's been a few bumps in
the road since I arrived here but after
meeting osama's family my dream of
marrying Osama is starting to become
more of a reality and I'm starting to
feel like okay we're headed in the right
direction now or are they because after
seeing the teas for next week I'm
rethinking her entire conversation with
his family
or something I want to talk about
serious things and you act like oh
you're crazy you're mentally ill
our plan is you will bring me to the USA
and we start Outlet there if you don't
accept this we can't stop all this what
where do I start
first of all he wants to call Miss
Debbie Craig
if you don't have anything next say
don't say nothing at all okay
okay
see I don't like that when someone has
been vulnerable with you and opened up
about what they've gone through in
regards to their mental health struggles
how did you come out of that dark space
well it was due to Osama
you don't turn around and weaponize it
against them you have the amount of
seconds or something and he's the one
who said he had madness in him I know
that there
inside of me
that I showed you in my poetry and in my
painting
let me calm down because that was just a
clip I don't even have the full context
yet but based off what we just saw from
that sneak peek I have a feeling that
usama's family is aware of his desire to
go to the states and they support it and
that's why they are supporting this
relationship
just a berry but I did put my
investigator hat on
[Music]
and I remembered also in the car on the
way to his parents house Usama said this
which had me a bit suspicious before I
even saw the tease for next week
I hope they can understand you know
where I'm coming from that I'm not
stealing their son every mother and
father once from the floor this song for
the children are future
a future a future in America
look when someone says something that
hits my intuition in the wrong way I do
not hesitate to ask
what do you mean once for their children
a future what exactly do you mean by
that Usama
like I said let me relax until we get
the full story it's just that Debbie is
such a kind person you don't mess with
kind people
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time
foreign